hi i'm kyla pratt and i play penny pro
hi i'm joe marie payton and i play sugar
mama hello i'm paula j parker and i am
trudy hi i'm tommy davis and i play the
voice of oscar proud trudeau hi i'm ej
johnson and i play michael and we are
here with buzzfeed to find out which
proud family member we really are we're
not who we really are kyla i don't know
[Music]
the first question we have is pick a
former guest star from the original
series we have mariah carey as mariah
carey omarion as 15 cent kobe bryant as
kobe bryant cicely tyson as maureen
parker jennifer lewis as sister spice
alicia keys as alicia keys cedric the
entertainer as bobby proud cheryl lee
ralph as diana parker and kell mitchell
as carlos so hard
it's hard because i just want so many
good ones because it's kobe you know but
choose it then
i also like cheryl the one that i chose
just because i feel like
i'm i'm basically her in like a couple
years it's jennifer lewis oh i knew you
were going to do your best
you had to i loved it
i picked jennifer lewis also
right sugar mama that's my sister on the
show yeah who did you pick mama i'm
trying to okay i'm just going to close
my eyes because i want to pick colby
because it's kobe and i'm going to do
that yeah
who did you pick tommy i picked alicia
keys yeah because i just love her
i don't know why tommy alicia keys just
fixed you to me i just feel like you
just moved like she just survived
which role do you play in your family
the black sheep the peacemaker the
goofball the nosy nelly the life of the
party the loose cannon the caretaker the
control freak the outlet one can we pick
more than one i'm all of them
just pick one so we can get home
i got it which i'll pick
i'm the life of the party obviously
i picked the life of the party also i
picked the control freak okay see and i
feel like i was being extra honest and i
picked the control freak too because i
realized
choose some hollywood siblings to hang
with oh
belong and beyonce knowles beanie
feldstein and jonah hill chloe and
hayley bailey bella and gigi hadid jaden
and willow smith ashley elizabeth and
mary kate olsen taj mahari and tia mowry
the jonas brothers liam and chris
hemsworth now this is hard okay it's
some cool people in this
i'm gonna have to go with jaden and
willow because i remember them being
babies and i picked chloe and hallie
because i'm trying to be in the group
you know what i'm saying and i'm right
yes baby i pick solange and beyonce no
yes uh because you're blind no because i
i like their energy i picked jayden and
willow smith because they probably got a
jet
i'm picking
ashley so we can pull new york fashion
looks together
that's a good reason too yep right on
time
how would your bffs describe you
supportive then i feel like fred
sanford
okay
very
creative honest carefree warm-hearted
goofy a dreamer edible
that's not fair i feel like i'm all of
these
yeah i feel like i'm a lot of these we
have to pick one okay yeah it could be a
bff
yeah i can see that for you that's why i
put on my glasses because if i couldn't
see it i had to see honesty
i'ma say i'm creative since college all
my girlfriends have seen me as the one
with this dream that seemed unattainable
and then i did it
yes
i'm gonna look hair free i think i went
with going-hearted i really feel like
anyone would say i'm all of these but
i'm gonna go with what the first thing
probably would be is goofy
pick a throwback disney channel show to
binge that's so raven lizzie mcguire
hannah montana even stevens wizards of
waverly place the sweet life of zach and
cody phil of the future kim possible and
the famous jet jackson this is easy
that's a raven for me
you did mention them earlier that is my
favorite one of my favorite shows of all
time like i'm that's you're waiting for
me also
visit your waverly place that's so
raving for me too i feel like i'm gonna
have to go with the famous jet jackson
oh i love him
i miss him
oh like who is this flying man
you know like yeah
finally tell me one thing you're proud
of my ambition i'm striving for
greatness my heart i've been through a
lot my resilience i never give up my
tribe my friends and family keep me home
my glow up i look and feel good my
growth i've come a long way my morals i
refuse to let society dictate my life my
bounce back i look at failures as
lessons intuition is never steered me
wrong i have my my resilience and i
never give up yes
i think i'm my intuition because that's
kind of encompasses a lot more and like
i always trust myself okay i'll pick
my growth i've come a long way baby like
a virginia slim oh
yeah i'm gonna pick my heart it's been
through a lot oh
i think i'm gonna go with my morals i
refuse to let society dictate my life
i'm i'm also that one but like i just
chose i feel you on the intuition thing
because that baby is strong everybody's
like oh we never see anything crazy
about you i said cause uh i'll be
listening to myself i know what's going
on
i'm gonna tell mine yet but i'm not
going first
together she's a little bit older than i
i've always looked at her like a big
sister
i
she was always my favorite character on
the show you know before michael so i'm
like this is perfect for me because like
she's the bougie one and like i'm always
the bushy one
so far are we two for two because i see
it i do too
all right la siena boulevard
the divas i got it who you got cause i
have an idea
what's that
i'll take her anytime man you kidding me
my show was
make sure you tune in for the premiere
of the prowl family louder and prouder
on disney plus don't miss out
oh yeah
[Music]
you